so the election of Member of Parliament  for Natyam south on Thursday the 8th of  June 2017 I in Korea being the acting  returning officer that the above the  election do hereby give notice that the  number of votes recorded for each  candidate at said election is as follows  Greenwood Lilian Rachel Labour Party  thirty thousand and thirteen  [Applause]  Halas David Ian UK Independence Party  1103 hunt  Jane Marian the Conservative Party  candidate 14850 one  [Applause]  McGregor Adam Fergus the Green Party 598  [Applause]  Sutton Tony Bernhard the Liberal  Democrats 1564  there were 137 ballot papers rejected I  do here  I do hereby declare that Lillian Rachel  Greenwood is duly elected to the ward of  notting himself  [Applause]